going back to 2006 what did you do to
make the film go viral or I know realize
you didn't orchestrate it but to prompt
it to go viral you know I think I think
the movie had like one of the first of
all we started out with this idea that
we were just going to make a really
crappy and I can say that now you know I
don't think at the time we said the word
crappy but we were going to make this
really crappy low-budget zombie movie
and just sell it to the highest bidder
so we can make our next movie and that
was sort of the old paradigm if you
remember that's how everybody used to
think about moviemaking prior to the VOD
revolution you know this was still the
era of DVDs but what we didn't realize
is 2005-2006 things were shifting where
we were shifting away from like hey
we're just going to sell it to the
highest bidder to now video and demands
coming in here and it's going to start
chomping away at some of the DVD
potential out there so in order to make
the movie go viral first of all we
started with a hook it was incredibly
memorable I'm almost like at this point
I've grown so far past it that I almost
don't like talking about it but it was
it was the hook what it was zombies that
attack a camp for the mentally
challenged and that was our hook we were
going to make this outrageous movie but
I will tell you that through the years
and this was back in two thousand six
we've gotten responses for special needs
communities to where they were like
Jason we loved how you made the heroes
you know you never cross the line
everybody was empowered to become the
zombie fighting action heroes and in
fact our tagline was sometimes heroes
ride the short bus so once that got out
on the internet once we posted a teaser
trailer on youtube it did skyrocketed
that trailer ended up on so many
different websites you know the types of
sites that post those things like
gorilla mask and college humor and
national lampoon's and you name it it
was out there and people were sharing it
and that was driving traffic back to our
to our primary website for the movie
except at the time I firstly I didn't
know a lot about internet marketing I
was just
learning the basics so we weren't
capturing any of the traffic that was
coming to our site we just left it kind
of fall off the map and you know in
retrospect that was a huge mistake
because we're talking like there were
over a hundred thousand people that came
to that site and I just you know where I
don't have those emails to this day you
just we didn't do anything to capture so
all of this was taking place the movie
was going viral and meanwhile we were
still waiting as most filmmakers do for
this million-dollar distribution deal I
mean imagine that like thinking about it
today that it sounds ludicrous because
now you you might look at it as a modern
movie maker and say I have a hundred
thousand people coming to my website why
don't why do I even need a distributor
you know because you can access the
marketplace you can have a link on your
website that takes people where you need
to go to make the sale but we just
weren't thinking that way were you using
myspace at the time also to promote it
or what were you using in terms of
social media that's awesome that you
brought up myspace yeah as a matter of
fact myspace was one of the early tools
that we were using and I remember doing
like some this is where I was getting in
internet marketing in it I've always
been into computers so it just made
sense to me this idea that you could go
out on these websites and find people
that were interested in your type of
movie and then market directly to them
so myspace had some tools set up that
we're really primitive but you were able
to target interest and I and I had
bought this piece of software that
allowed me to find people that were in
the zombie movies and I just started
emailing a lot of those people and
saying hey we just did the zombie movie
come check it out we found that that
helped you know that helped a little bit
it was very one-on-one sending emails
but what I didn't realize is that one on
one engagement I was building
relationships with my audience without
even thinking about them you know the
way we talk everybody talks about
audience engagement today like it's
something you can buy in a box but back
then I think that was real deal
grassroots audience engagement get
actually getting to know the people in
your audience and then a few of those
people would go out and spread word and
bring more traffic back to the website
so it was cool but one of the things
that really drove traffic was a stumble
upon being a social bookmarking site
that was really interesting to us we
found that the vast majority of our
traffic after time was coming from
people stumbling and then sharing it
with their communities and sharing it
with their communities and so on and so
forth and then interestingly the only ad
dollars we spent and it was probably
only a few hundred dollars you know if
you were to add it all up through the
years was to grease the wheels and
stumble upon because I found that for
five cents you could go in there and
find somebody that was you know loosely
targeted somebody into horror movies and
I could pay to have them see our website
from the movie and that was cool because
we were getting what they call an
internet marketing conversion rate the
amount of people that actually come your
site and by what it is you want them to
buy I don't remember the figures but
stumbleupon was delivering for that
particular movie a really good
conversion rate which meant people were
stumbling and they were like oh I got to
buy it now that was cool I'm just for
the record I've since tried stumbleupon
for about every other movie I've worked
on and it's never caught on quite the
same way so I think you have to have
some weird memorable hook almost to the
point of exploitation speaking about
that in like a very gentle way like some
in other words it has to be so
remarkable that people can walk away
from a party and be like yeah I met the
guy that's making that weird zombie
movie and like they remember it but if
you're like the guy that's making that
you know the movie about purple pinecone
it's like maybe that's not as exciting
to people right and you built the
website yourself I had a good buddy from
college named Tom so cash that still
builds websites and he built our
original website originally it was like
this really awesome flash website that
we went there you had people screaming
and then blood flew up on the screen and
there was some music and he even built
this like flash player that this is
before we put the movie on YouTube but
what we found when we went from the
period of time that where you're
promoting the movie while you're in
festivals what we found was there's time
where you go from promoting the time you
go to selling and what we found was
there was a lot of traffic getting lost
on all the behind-the-scenes photos and
all the extra stuff that you really
need so that's when we whittled the site
down and said okay you know here's the
logo here's the tag lines from
testimonials the trailer and a big Buy
Now button so going back to two thousand
six what still works from that
experience and what as is totally
outdated well I think well I think what
works from that experience is still you
have to come up with a movie it's
remarkable that people are going to talk
about that they're going to remember and
I think if you're an unknown filmmaker
while I wouldn't advocate you know
getting quite as risque as we did you
should come up with a concept that has a
little bit of this a little bit
polarizing where people either like it
or hate it because I think if you hit
that middle ground and a lot of
filmmakers try to play safe in that
middle ground especially first-time
filmmakers because they don't want to
offend people like their mom by the way
my mom loved our movie okay only because
we never crossed headline i got think I
feel like I have to keep bringing that
up because for those reasons like back
then I was like oh so controversial an
awesome and now I've been in the
profession for so long then I'm like
wait that's my first movie like do we
have to keep talking about it you know
well is that the litmus test then do you
kind of push it so maybe you can't show
it to your mom and dad I know that you
know because there's people they'll say
that right and i think i agree with it
to a point but it still has to be good
movie you know it's one thing to have a
concept where people are like I got to
see that and that's what most movies try
to do anyway with their trailers that
are advertising campaigns all that but
once they get to see it it still has to
hold up it has to be you know really
good or engaging on some front or it
either has to be so bad it's good you
know not that i know the filmmakers that
made the room but I've seen that I've
seen in the room and I'm like I've
watched it and I'm like I don't know
what this is about but it's awesome
because I don't because it's because
it's not so good and and to that
filmmakers credit in which I got to meet
him eventually to his credit my gosh he
he turned that around he's like it's a
it's a black comedy best movie of the
year like this this movie of the year
these are memorable pieces but I don't
know if it can be orchestrated
I think you can come up with like a
controversial hook but can you make a
movie within those within the hook that
that still holds people's interest you
know I think that's a challenge for all
filmmakers
you